all right so uh bigger picture to the
extent that the raiders are now
exasperated with antonio brown to the
point where mike mayak issues a lengthy
statement where it's clear that they
want him to i guess for lack of a better
term shut or get off the pot the uh
who's who's the blame in oakland for
the fact that they should have known
they knew or should have known what they
were getting into with antonio brown
they rushed into it they gave him 30
million guaranteed
what did they think was going to be
different chris they and surely if john
gruden calls mike tomlin you think mike
tom is going to lie to him about what a
pain in the ass antonio brown has been i
don't think so who's who's to blame for
welcoming this guy with opening arms and
and
you know acting surprised that he's
behaving this way yeah i mean ultimately
i think this is one that's got to go
back to john gruden that's why his
butt's on the line that's why you know
it's why i think we're seeing him not
make the comments of yesterday that mike
mayok made as far as drawing that line
in the sand because he knows he's the
reason antonio brown uh is there he
wants antonio brown to be his new toy
and he's trying to play as you said
during the show today he's good cop so
he can continue to continue to be good
cop and keep antonio brown in good
spirits and hey the offense is around
you and i'm designing all these plays
for you and mike mayo can be bad cop and
and certainly say no this nonsense has
to stop even though that's what john
gruden's saying as well but he's going
to let mike mayok say it and be the bad
guy and you know at the very least i
just hope this gives everybody a little
sympathy to mike tomlin in pittsburgh
that would be my big point here i mean
everybody talked about lack of
institutional control when it came to
antonio brown and mike tomlin and we're
seeing right now that man there's not
many institutions that can control this
guy it's just not that easy uh he and he
isn't a phenomenal football player but
hey i'll defend mike tomlin in this
aspect he's not the gm he didn't have
final say on the roster there was a true
gm in pittsburgh there you know here
with oakland john gruden we know has
complete and total power so i think
that's where it has to start as far as
you know at least we're gonna hold
somebody responsible it's him
one of the things i poked around a
little bit last week but it was
difficult because the steelers
organization was dealing with the
untimely passing and unexpected passing
of receivers coach daryl drake
i'm trying to figure out and i was at
the time and it kind of faded off the
radar screen as the story shifted and
changed but i'm going to double back on
this i'm curious
did the steelers know
what was coming with this helmet issue
and did they realize based upon their 10
years with antonio brown
this isn't going to end well
and
we better just you know to the extent
that there's a stew of factors that go
into a decision like this i can't help
but wonder whether at some level they
knew they're avoiding this potential
maybe shut air advantage shut storm that
was we got we got we got a thousand of
these punches but you know did they did
they know it and did they did they
deliberately say
we want to avoid this and now they're
sitting back saying hey the raiders are
dealing with what we were going to have
to deal with if we hadn't traded that's
a great question i mean it is i would
like to know the answer to that too i i
will say this just from people i've
talked to around the league i got a good
feeling though that the steelers knew
before antonio brown had his meltdown
late in the season the rift between him
and ben roethlisberger not showing up i
think they had a good inkling that
antonio brown was about to stir the pot
and that he was afraid that he might not
see any more money in pittsburgh and he
was going to force himself out of town
i think they had at least a few warning
signs and i don't know if they were
totally shocked by some of the antics
antonio brown pulled at the end of the
season and into the off season to make
sure that he got out of there i'll i'll
i have certainly been led to believe
that
well he got what he wanted by way of a
contract that carried 30 million fully
guaranteed but he isn't going to get any
of it he's going to have to pay back the
million that he already got in the form
of a signing bonus if he doesn't just
grab a different helmet and show up for
work unless he's got something else up
his sleeve that can work and that only
thing that i can envision is a grievance
attacking the nfl's abrupt decision to
test the shutter advantage to eliminate
that as a an acceptable model that a
player can use and not give him a
one-year grace period to move forward in
that helmet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports